hours before Malaysia shut its borders
thousands of Malaysian workers who
normally commute to work in Singapore
every day rushed to leave students also
formed long lines at bus terminals as
confusion over whether campuses which
shut prompted many to try to leave two
police stations were crowded after
people were told they would require
permits for interstate travel only for
police to temporarily withdraw the order
even after the partial lockdown was
imposed social distancing was forgotten
as buyers rushed to supermarkets to
stock up on essentials infectious
diseases experts have watched with alarm
at what's happening here the
director-general of health has warned of
a possible third wave of infections if
people don't obey the government's order
to restrict their movements Malaysia has
confirmed its first debts and reported a
sudden spike in kovat 19 cases in the
last few days many linked to afford a
gathering of Muslim missionaries at a
mosque near Kuala Lumpur 16 thousand
people from Malaysia and abroad were
there the government says it's managed
to trace more than 8,000 of them so far
but already those who attended the event
have carried the virus back to six of
the Southeast Asian countries elsewhere
Australia's Prime Minister made an
unprecedented announcement we are
upgrading the travel ban on Australians
to level 4 for the entire world that is
the first time that has ever happened in
Australia's history the travel advice to
every Australian is do not travel abroad
do not go overseas the Australian
Government's also banned all
non-essential indoor gatherings of more
than a hundred people but from who Bay
Province in China the origin of the
corona virus outbreak more cause for
optimism medical workers from other
provinces who've been helping to cope
with the crisis are going home as the
number of new cases continues to fall
South Korea reported fewer than a
hundred new daily cases for the fourth
day in
roll both China and South Korea
apparently demonstrating how they are
winning the war albeit with different
methods China by placing severe
restrictions for everyone in South Korea
with aggressive testing Florence lui al
Jazeera Kuala Lumpur